to the sexual Marketplace females have  always been and still to a degree are  The Gatekeepers it's men will you can  think about it in a very simplistic way  this is not the case but let's simplify  it for the sake of argument imagine men  will run around and [ __ ] anything  and women are the ones who say yes or no  you are The Gatekeepers that have all  the power and this is what's actually  truly interesting about the sexual  Marketplace because whenever women go  there's not enough good men then why are  you [ __ ] of course why would they be  good if you don't make them be good  you're a [ __ ] losers  so women so you're talking about I'm  saying that you know the man a certain  level can't do certain things if you  were with Joe schmoe and he wasn't  treating you the way you believe Joe  Shmo should treat you then why you  wouldn't leave OB